ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الاول
مده زمنيه طويله قطعتها تونس قبل ان تفاجئ
جزيره جربه السياحيه جنوب شرق البلاد
بهجوم مسلح نفذه عنصر امن في الحرس الوطني
قتل خلاله زائران احدهما فرنسي كان
يشاركان في احتفالات دينيا يهودي في كنيس
الغريبه بالجزيره المهاجم قتل ايضا اثنين
من زملائه في الحرس الوطني التونسي وجرح
اخرين ويتزمن هذا الهجوم مع اليوم الاخير
من موسم حج اليهود السنوي الى كنيسه
الغريبه الذي يعتبر اقدم معابد اليهود في
شمال افريقيا حيث شهد مشاركه اكثر من 5000
يهودي جاء معظمهم من الخارج وفي تفاصيل
هذه الحادثه التي فتحت فيها وزاره
الداخليه تونسيه تحقيقا فقد بدا الهجوم
بقتل المهاجم لزميله والاستيلاء على سلاحه
ثم انتقل المنفذ باتجاه محيط معبد الغريبه
وهو يطلق النار بشكل عشوائي قبل ان ترضيه
قوات الامن قتيلا وعقب الحادث تم نشر قوات
الامس في محيط الكنيس واغلاق جميع الطرق
المؤديه اليه كما دفعت السلطات التونسيه
بتعزيزات من الجيش الوطني الى الجزيره
ياتي هذا الهجوم في وقت تسجل السياحه
التونسيه انتعاشا جيدا بعد تباطؤ حاد خلال
لائحه كورونا
هجوم جربه ابرز ردود الفعل التونسيه
والدوليه
الخارجيه التونسيه هجوم جبان والتحقيق جار
لتحديد المسؤوليات
وزير السياحه التونسيه هجوم يزيد من تماسك
البلاد
اتحاد الشغل عمليه ارهابيه جبانه وعلى
السلطات تدارك اي خلل امني محتمل
حزب تونس النهضه تقف وراء الارهاب في
البلاد وهجوم جربه يتزامن مع محاسبه
الغنوشي
الرئيس الفرنسي قال ان الهجوم على كنيس
الغريبه يقلقنا ونفكر بالم بالضحايا
وبالشعب التونسي
الولايات المتحده نددت بالهجوم واثنت على
تحرك قوات الامن التونسيه بسرعه لوقف
الهجوم
نناقش كل هذه التطورات مع ضيوفنا من تونس
الدكتور علي العلانيه الباحثه في الشؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه اهلا بك ومن تونس دائما
العميد خليفه الشيباني المحلل الامني اهلا
بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع
الدكتور علي دكتور عليا ما تبعناه من
تطورات شهدها معبد الغريبه في جربه هل
نتحدث عن مجموعات ارهابيه لا زالت تتحرك
في تونس هل هي ذئاب منفرده هل هذا استثناء
ام الموضوع
ليس ارهابي الموضوع امني بالاساس
مساء الخير تحيه لكم ولضيفكم الكريم ولكل
الساده المشاهدين
اعتقد ان يعني هذا هذا الهجوم يمكن نعته
بالارهاب كتحليل ولكن كمعطيات رسميه لا
نزال ننتظر بيان من وزاره الداخليه تحدد
طبيعه القاتل
ان كان يعمل يعني
كذئب منفرد يعمل لصالحه او لصالح غيره
بطبيعه الحال هناك مؤشرات اوليه تدل على
ان هذا الهجوم يمكن ان يحمل بصمات الهجوم
الارهابي فالقاتل في البدايه كان الذي قتل
زميله كان يحمل ستره واقيه وكان قد اخذ
سلاحه زميله وكان قد قرر الذهاب مباشره
الى
الكنيسه اليهودي رغم مسافه المسافه
البعيده بعشرين كي لكنه كان يخفي يعني
شخصيته باعتباره كان يلبس لباس الحرس
الوطني اذا هو وقع التفطن اليه عندما
اقترب من معبد الغريبه من الجهه الخلفيه
تشكك فيه
الحراس الامنيون وعندما احس هذا القاتل
بانه اصبح محل شك بدات الدكتور علي ما
معنى ما معنى لانه لحقته الشكوك لانه كان
يلبس لباس الحرس الوطني هو عنصر في مؤسسه
الحرس الوطني صحيح
انا قلت لاحقته الشكوك عندما وصل هو كان
لابسا للباس الحرس الوطني لو لم يكن لابسا
لباس الحركه الوطني لما تمكن من الوصول
الى قريب قريب من المعبد لكن تصرفاته
اعتبرت لدى الحراس الامن انها غريبه نوعا
ما وبطبيعه الحال بدا يرتبك وتم تبادل
اطلاق النار واتينا ونحن على يعني الرجال
الامن وعلى التونسيين الاخرين الذين قتل
كزوار يعني قتل في هاته العمليه
سناتي الى تفاصيل هذه العمليه وسناتي كذلك
الى استفهام طرحه كسر هو ينتمي لمؤسسه
الحرس الوطني مع احترام كل التونسيين في
الواقع ونحن تابعنا تعليقات وتفاعل
التونسيين مع مؤسسه الحرس الوطني التي
دافعت كذلك مع هذه العمليه
على معبد الغريبه ولكن كيف لهذه الشخصيه
ان تكون موجوده داخل مؤسسه الحرس الوطني
ربما اسال في هذا الاطار سيد خليفه
الشيباني سيد خليفه هذا الموضوع تعلم
حضرتك بانه موضوع جد حساس اولا لانه
مؤسسات الامن في تونس تحترم وهناك مسانده
لها لانها تقوم باعمال كبيره ولكن هذا لا
ينفي بان هناك عناصر منذ فتره وهناك شقوق
بخصوص دخول عناصر متطرفه الى هذه المؤسسات
وبالتالي هل هناك منهج لادخالهم
ولااقحامهم في مثل هكذا عمليات
ده هو مساء الخير لك ولكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه الغراوي لضيفك الكريم هو اولا
الساعه خلينا نكونو معناها نقولوا ان سلك
الحرس الوطني او الدرك الوطني مثل ما
يسميه شقائنا في الشرق هو كان في طليعه
القوات المحاربه للارهاب اولا القوات
الاخرى لكن هو اكثر العمليات الناجحه في
تونس قام بها سلك الحرس الوطني هذا اولا
ثانيا معناها
الحدث هذايا متاع العمليه الارهابيه وحتى
الشهداء الذين قدموا من قوات الامنيه
والعسكريه هو الحرس الوطني ياتي في مقدمه
الذين دفعوا دمائهم شهداء حتمع المؤسسه
الامنيه الاخرى لكن هو يجيب في المرتبه
الاولى معنا في مكافحه الارهاب وفي
الشهداء الذين قدمهم النقطه الاولى النقطه
الثانيه هو ان من دافعوا نحن تجنبنا
الاسوء في هذه العمليه لانه كان المخطط له
ان يقتحم معناها معبد الغريبه وكانت تكون
الخسائر فظيعه في اعتقادي لانه اذا كان في
مكان ضيق ويتم معناها اطلاق النار بصوره
مسترسله فان الاعداد كانت تكون بالعشرات
الحاجه الاخرى هو ان الامنيه في تونس
خلافا ل 2011 ما قبل 2011 قبل 2011 الساعه
من كانت له اي شبهه دينيه بالتطرف الديني
لا يدخل الى المؤسسه الامني وحتى من يتم
التفطر اليه بعد مده فيتم عزله من المؤسسه
الامنيه الامور كانت واضحه في تونس بعد
2011 ما حدث هو عمليه معناها تفتيت
المؤسسه الامنيه هو ان حتى الارشادات التي
كانت تتم عاده ويتم الاسترشاد سواء على
الاعوان او عن الضباط في اعتقاد هذه
المنظومه قد سقطت اضافه الى ان اعاده
المعزولين بعد 2011 الى سلك الامن كان
فيهم العشرات ممن لهم انتماءات بالتالي
هناك منظومه كامله كانت تقوم على تحصين
المؤسسه الامنيه في اعتقادي في العشر
سنوات الاخيره هذه قد تم التلاعب بها
والتلاعب بها بصفه مقصوده فاعتقادي وليست
صفه عفويه اليوم الذي حدث هو ان العمليه
معناها هو الطقوس كلها تمت في ظروف عاديه
ناهيك ان كافه معناها مراحل غريبه قد
انتهت ثم ان العمليه تاتي من
الساعه هي ليست الاولى في العمليات
الارهابيه في العالم معناه شاهدنا العديد
من الجنود سواء في قواعد او في اماكن اخرى
قد قاموا بها لكن هذه في تونس في اعتقاده
هي العمليه الاولى التي يقوم بها عون امن
بهذه الطريقه حضرتك تتحدث وتقول بان هناك
قصد هناك نوع تقول بان هذه العمليه مقصوده
دكتور علي
مقصوده بمعنى هناك مستفيد من المستفيد من
هذا التطور من هذه العمليه في الغريبه
يعني يمكن ان نقول ان المستفيدين يعني
ربما يعني كثيرون اولا التيارات الارهابيه
التي لم تستطع ان تقوم بعمليات ارهابيه
كبيره بعد 2019 يعني بعد ارتقاء الرئيس
قيس سعيد الى الحكم قبل 2019 كانت في تونس
من 2011 الى 2019 حوالي 70 عمليه ارهابيه
بعد 2019 اكثر من 90% من العمليات
الارهابيه سبقا لم تحصل وبالتالي هؤلاء
الذين يتمنون حصول عمليات ارهابيه من
مصلحتهم ان تقع مثل هذه العمليه هذا اولا
ثانيا بالنسبه الى تزامن العمليه مع الوضع
يعني السياسي الذي تعيشه تونس راى بعض
المحللين ان ربما هذا التزامن يعني كان
معناها نوع من تخوف بعض الفئات
وبعض المسؤولين ربما يعني يعتبرون ان تغير
هذا النظام
واستمرار
القيام بالاصلاحات للمنظومه الامنيه
والاقتصاديه والمحاسبه ربما هذا سيكون
خطرا عليهم فلعل بعض هؤلاء من مصلحتهم
استمرار الاحتقان بالنسبه
لحركه النهضه سالا يسال بعض المحلين هل
هناك علاقه بين ايقافات للسيد الغنوشي
ويعني ما حصل البارحه نحن هذا لا يمكن ان
نجزم فيه الا اذا ظهرت المعطيات من طرف
وزاره الداخليه بان هذه العمليه لها صبغه
ارهابيه 100% لان كما قلت في البدايه يمكن
ان يكون هذا العون يعمل كذئب منفرد يمكن
ان يعمل لصالحه او لصالح غيره ويمكن ان
يكون من من ورائه شبكه يعني تقوم باعانته
هذا سيظهر عندما يعني تبدا
تتضح الصوره بخصوص طبيعه العمليه
الارهابيه لكن الاهم من ذلك الذين كانوا
يريدون من العمليه ان تنجح فشلوا في ذلك
لماذا هناك عده مؤشرات يعني اليوم هناك
باصات عديده حافلات عديده خرجت من جربه
الى قابس اكثر من خمسه حافلات وذهبت
لزياره مزار يعني يهودي قديم يعني السيد
يوسف المعرابي يذهب اليه اليهود كل سنه
وهناك ايضا رئيس الطائفه اليهوديه الذي
قال ان كل الرحلات
تنطلق من جربه الى داخل البلاد التونسيه
يعني ستكون هذه الرحلات
هذه التفاصيل بالتالي حضرتك تشير بانه هذا
التطور هذا الهجوم لم ينعكس سلبا على حركه
تواجد اليهود في تونس او حتى على موسم
حجهم في الغريبه او حتى على تنقلاتهم
السياحيه ولكنك اتيت على تفصيل ان تحدثت
عن ثلاث مستفيدين وهنا اسال حضرتك سيد
الشيباني ضيفي تحدث وافترض ان تكون هذه
العمليه تقف وراءها مجموعه ارهابيه تقف
وراءها اياد سياسيه وتحدث كذلك عن حزب
النهضه ولو انه لم اسال عن هذا الموضوع
ولا اعلم دكتور عليا لماذا من دون كل
الاحزاب تحدثت عن حزب النهضه ولكنك طرحتها
في شكل انه مراقبين هم من
طرحوا مثل هكذا استفهام بالنظر الى حمله
التوقيفات التي شهدها اعضاء في النهضه ما
رايك في كل هذا الكلام سيد شيباني
ما هو رايي اولا الساعه هي على استحياء هم
اصدروا بيانات على استحياء العمليه الان
لها اكثر من تقريبا 18 ساعه لم يصدر بيان
عندما يتم ايقاف اي رمز من رموزا بعد نصف
ساعه تصدر البيانات اليوم حتى البيان صدر
في هذا المساء وهو على استحياء معناه انا
مستغرب حتى من المنظمات الوطنيه معناه
كافه الاحزاب لم تستر بيان الى حدود ساعه
منتصف النهار من
اليوم اليوم دائما من المستفيدين ان نسهل
على المستفيدين ثم ان ظرفيه الحاليه التي
يتواجد فيها هذه اسئله يطرحها على شارع
التونسي انا لست محللا قضائيا ولست قاضيا
هنا ولكن اذهب في التحليل عندما اشاهد
الابجديه السابقه التي كانت تتعذر على ان
هؤلاء يمثلون الاسلام الغاضب وهؤلاء هم
ابنائنا وان الجيش غير مضمون وتلفت كافه
هذه الابجديه بالتالي هناك اصبح اليوم
تشار الى هذا الوضع اليوم كذلك زاد لانه
نحن تبين اننا ليس موحدين ضد الارهاب لان
الارهاب يطلب وحده وطنيه هناك من كانوا
داخل مجلس النواب معناها مسجد العمليه
التي استهدفت الاستاذ في فرنسا على خلفيه
نحن نعيش في تونس ونحن نعيش في الارهاب
هناك العديد من الناس في ادبياتهم وفي
معناها كلماتهم وفي اعتقاد الاسلام
السياسي هو العديد من التساؤلات في الشارع
التونسي اليوم اليوم في معركه الكل على
الكل اصبح كل شيء مباح في تونس انا اليوم
مثلي مثل الشارع التونسي شارع كان ينتظر
رده فعل
العمليه حدثت تقريبا بين الثامنه والتاسعه
مساء بتوقيت تونس ولا حديث ولا تصريحه ولا
كلام ولكن رايناهم عندما يتم قياد احدهم
او يتم استدعائه الى اي بحث فان دوما
الدنيا تقف ولا تقع بالتالي هنا انا انا
لست انا انا لست قاضيا لكن الابحاث ستبين
ان العمليه هو ان السيد هذا قد تقدم الى
المركز بمفرده الى اعتقد ولكن نحن الان لا
نتحدث عن عمليه ارهابيه نكتفي بمقالته
وزاره الداخليه انه عمل غادر وجبان ولكن
في التحليل عندما نشاهد ان السيد قد قام
عنها الاسلحه وقصد معبد الغريبه نعرف ان
الاهداف وخلفياتها فاعتقاد بالبصمات يمكن
ان نعرف انها عمليه ارهابيه حاجه اخرى
تطرح التساؤل الى الان لم يتم اي جهه لم
تقم بتبني هذه العمليه وفي اعتقاد هذا
سؤال اخر زاد يطرح في هذا المجال حاليا
لماذا دكتور عليها لم تتبنى اي جهه هذه
العمليه وهنا كذلك يطرح سؤال فيما يتعلق
بالفتره السابقه لم تشهد فيها تونس هجمات
ارهابيه لماذا عادت هذه الهجمات هل لا
زالت تونس ارضا خصبه لمثل هكذا هجوم
اعتقد ان عوده الازمات يعني فيها قراءات
عديده لانه بعد 2019 كما قلت منذ قليل
نقصت كثيرا العمليات الارهابيه
ولكن الاهم لماذا يعني اعاده بعض هذه
العمليات اذا عادت لان قطار الاصلاحات
وقطار المحاسبه بدا ياخذ شوطا طويلا
وبالتالي كما قلت هناك اطراف متعدده
ومتنوعه من مشارب واديولوجيات ربما مختلفه
من مصلحتها ان تكون يعني ان يكون هناك عدم
استقرار في تونس
وسواء كان هذا القاتل يعمل لحسابه او
لحساب غيره فالنتيجه واحده هي ان ان ما
حصل كان من يريد توظيفه قد فشل في الحصول
هذا التوظيف نظرا لان وكالات الاسفار
اعلنت انه ليست هناك الغاء لحجوز السياحه
ونحن نعرف ان جربه هي مدينه سياحيه
بامتياز وايضا كما قلت ان عوده الارهاب
بعد هذه الهدنه الطويله هي تخوف من ان
مسار الاصلاحات سينتهي بطي صفحه المشهد
السياسي القديم لان هناك الان الخطوات
كبيره وهامه جدا في اصلاح المنظومه
الامنيه وقد وقع تغيير العديد من القيادات
الامنيه منذ اسابيع وهذا مؤشر هام وبعد
ذلك بدات ايضا منظومه الاصلاح الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه ويعني مساله التسفير وغير ذلك
اذا هناك رعب في بعض الاوصات يخشون من ان
يعني تكون تونس على موعد مع معافاه يعني
تامه وبالتالي ارادوا ان تقع بعض هذه
العمليات مع الاشاره الى ان مثل هذه تحصل
في اكبر الدول واعطاها التي تملك
نعم وضحت الفتره
صحيح والاكيد بان سنبقى في متابعه هذه
التطورات اعذرني انتهى تماما توقيت الملف
الخاص بهذا الموضوع اعتذر منك شكرا جزيلا
لك على الحضور من تونس دكتور علي العلاني
الباحث في شؤون الجماعه المتطرفه وشكر
كذلك للعميد خليفه الشيباني المحلل الامني
شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات